gerardo leyó un estudio que analizaba la
conexión entre el uso de teléfonos
inteligentes y la felicidad con base en
datos de aproximadamente 5 mil
adolescentes elegidos aleatoriamente el
estudio encontró que en promedio los
adolescentes que pasan más tiempo usando
teléfonos inteligentes son
significativamente menos felices que
aquellos que pasan menos tiempo usando
teléfonos inteligentes gerardo concluyó
que usar más tiempo teléfonos
inteligentes hace menos felices a los
adolescentes esto es muy interesante
ahora les pido que piensen si la
conclusión de gerardo es válida o no y
cuál sería la razón que justifique esa
respuesta vamos a resolverlo juntos
comprender esto es importante porque
vemos cosas como estas publicadas en
medios de comunicación populares que
tratan de establecer una causalidad
cuando ésta puede que no exista o que el
estudio no pueda mostrar que exista
causalidad en este momento gerardo dice
que concluye que el uso de teléfonos
inteligentes hace que los adolescentes
sean menos felices es decir que se
supone una conexión causal en el uso de
teléfonos inteligentes que ocasiona que
los adolescentes sean menos felices en
realidad puede
a esta conclusión a partir de este
estudio con base en cómo se diseñó lo
primero que debemos preguntarnos es si
se trata de un estudio experimental
diseñado para establecer causalidad o si
es un estudio observacional donde
solamente se puede decir que existe una
asociación pero no se puede hacer una
afirmación acerca de la causalidad
recordemos que en un estudio
experimental se debe tener un grupo de
control y un grupo de tratamiento
también llamado grupo experimental
digamos que este es el grupo de control
ce y este es el de tratamiento o
experimental t luego asignamos
aleatoriamente personas a cada grupo y
se hace que las personas en el grupo
experimental usen más sus teléfonos
inteligentes para ver si se vuelven
menos felices esto no es lo que se hizo
aquí el enunciado describe un estudio
observacional en el cual se analizan dos
variables el uso del teléfono
inteligente y la felicidad del
adolescente luego se eligieron
aleatoriamente a 5.000 adolescentes y se
midió cuánto tiempo usaban sus teléfonos
inteligentes y su nivel de felicidad y
se hicieron esto mediante una encuesta
y graficaron los datos obtenidos 5000
datos de manera que este dato representa
un adolescente muy feliz que no usa
mucho su teléfono y este punto
representa un adolescente que no es muy
feliz y que si usa mucho su teléfono se
grafican todos estos datos y podría
haber alguna adolescente que no sea muy
feliz y que no use mucho su teléfono y
otro que si sea muy feliz y que si usa
mucho su teléfono pero podemos ver que
hay una tendencia o una asociación que
muestra que en general los adolescentes
que usan más sus teléfonos parecen ser
menos felices y que los adolescentes que
usan menos sus teléfonos parecen ser más
felices aquí es importante darnos cuenta
de que la causalidad podría ir en
sentido opuesto quizá los adolescentes
que son menos felices usan más sus
teléfonos inteligentes y quizá los
adolescentes más felices no sienten la
necesidad de usar tanto sus teléfonos o
incluso podría existir una variable que
no esté incluida en el estudio y que
tenga una relación causal con estas dos
variables así que podría existir otra
variable que podría ocasionar que
alguien fuera menos feliz y que usará
más su teléfono inteligente así
en un estudio observacional solo podemos
decir que existe una asociación pero no
podemos decir que existe causalidad por
lo que podemos decir que gerardo no está
haciendo una conclusión válida pues es
un estudio observacional en el cual sólo
se establece una asociación pero no
causalidad con eso terminamos y nos
vemos en el siguiente vídeo